so far we've covered many aspects of
using cloud operations to improve the
observability and reliability of your
services running on google cloud
but how should you approach setting up
and using the suite as your cloud
footprint grows
today we'll look at some enterprise best
practices that you can use to get the
most value out of cloud operations
welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
before we start let's take a step back
and answer this simple question why do
we do all of these things what are we
trying to achieve overall when using a
suite like cloud operations
ultimately we're after three main
objectives the first one is to ensure
that our services are secure and that we
comply with policies and regulations
that are specifically relevant in our
context
that means we need to manage things like
data access and an audit trail
the second one is the objective we've
talked about in just about every episode
keeping our users happy
that means we need to know if user
experience degrades hopefully by using
slos and what to do about it
the final goal is managing the capacity
required to run our services while
ensuring that we optimize for cost
with that said we'll tackle best
practices for setting up and using cloud
operations by focusing on these three
key areas
the first one and the one we'll focus on
today will be best practices for the
enterprise we'll cover setting up a
centralized logging and monitoring
environment ensuring audit trail and
configuring data retention and access
the next episode will address best
practices for using cloud monitoring
specifically we'll get into what to
monitor how to do it how to manage
alerts and how to optimize your
monitoring costs the final episode on
this topic will cover best practices for
cloud logging we'll get into what and
how to log how to use the logs your
services generate and how to optimize
your logging costs
this is going to be a lot but i think
you're ready let's get into it let's
start by talking about enterprise best
practices
the first recommendation is to
centralize monitoring auditing and
observability data in a single place
for services running on google cloud we
recommend using cloud operations to do
just that
having this information in a single
repository with easy cross-team access
greatly improves practices like
architecture design incident response
and root cause analysis
for example if i know the historical
reliability track record of my
dependencies i can better architect my
own service to meet my reliability
objectives at the same time i can do a
better job of incident response i can
see whether the services i depend on
having an incident it's really difficult
to do things like this without having
all this information in a single place
the second recommendation is to ensure
that a clear and easily accessible audit
trail exists for your services
this means using cloud audit logs to
help answer questions like who did what
where and when in your google cloud
projects and managing iem controls to
limit who has access to view audit logs
we've covered using audit logs in detail
in another video we'll link to it in the
show notes
as you make audit log configuration
changes use a test google cloud project
to validate them before propagating to
developer and production projects
when considering how you grant access to
audit logs across the organization we
recommend using your least privileged
approach to granting permissions we'll
link to specific examples of that in the
episode note
note that data access audit logs are off
by default except for bigquery when you
enable new google cloud services
evaluate whether or not to enable data
access audit logs for that new service
the final recommendation for enterprises
is to thoughtfully manage log retention
and analysis consider the various
retention needs for compliance
requirements security and access
analytics and event analytics we'll link
to documentation explaining specific
considerations for each scenario in the
episode notes
the first way to do this is by using log
views you can use log views to control
who has access to logs within your
logbuckets based on your needs and
requirements
custom log views provide you with a
granular way to control access to the
logs in your log buckets
you can also carefully control log
retention by using project level or
aggregated syncs to export logs to
bigquery cloud storage and pub sub for
analytics archival or consumption by
other systems
each of these do have their own
mechanisms for controlling retention and
access and you should carefully consider
those as you plan your retention
strategy
thanks for joining me today we covered
best practices for setting up and using
cloud operations in the enterprise
including centralizing data managing
audit trail and configuring data
retention i hope these recommendations
help you keep your services secure and
your users happy in our next episode
we'll tackle best practices for using
cloud monitoring thanks so much for
watching today don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out on more
engineering for reliability with google
cloud see you soon